some breaking news now as research by
britain's defense laboratory has shown a
product found in
insect repellent could kill the strain
of coronavirus that causes
covid 19. let's speak to our foreign
affairs editor debra haynes now hello to
deborah how significant
is this well i think it's uh it's a big
boost for the military because they
they were out on a limb a bit um
allowing their well getting their troops
to use this
insect repellent um since about april
um they basically it's the product
inside the repellent is called
citriodiol and
it's known to be effective as a barrier
against other forms of coronavirus it
hasn't got any adverse effect so the
thinking was
it probably would be effective against
this this new form of coronavirus that
causes
covert 19 so it started to be issued two
troops that were involved in the
coronavirus response if you remember
um as part of a sort of layered approach
along with
face masks and hand washing it's not a
sort of
a a barrier in itself it's part of a
whole load of measures
but since then the scientists at the
defense science and technology
laboratory
and the stl at port and down they've
been conducting research to try to
establish
if actually it does kill this strain of
coronavirus and they are
releasing their preliminary findings
today
and that shirt and they show that yes it
does
i think they're going to be wanting
other people to take on this research
and conduct
further research but but basically yes
it shows that this
insect repellent and it's only the
insect repellent that contains this
particular product
is an effective barrier against
coronavirus